I was just ready to double the points
let's try efore best buy test okay ah
Lopez land why not let's go for it I'm
very tempted to just take that night now
let's let's go with this quiet nice and
quiet here Bishop here just Castle let's
just Castle can I take this pawn and get
away with that or do I come earned some
heavy fire not gonna do it just yet I
want to see how I want to neutralize
this bishop he's very aggressively
placed and him of course now looking to
play on this side of the board I'm the F
file where do I want my knight on c3 or
d2 probably right here yep towards the
center jumping point there and I for
some reason I'm thinking the Knights
going to reroute like that is if I don't
Queen e1 to try and get on this
diagonals Knight here going to be
annoying it might it might be annoying
should I just take this Knight
how good is my Bishop even going to be
hmm let me see
okay I'm gonna do this if night before I
think I'll just play like cling to d2
okay now I'm very tempted to just take
this Knight very very tempted hmm she's
just backup Bishop a4 b5 I mean my pony
to pick up that if he really wants to oh
man
let me see I just don't know
take the night or not take the night
what do you do okay
getting angry with myself now what do
you do okay
let's see if they could put that Bishop
to work my knight is gone I think this
Bishop just has to come back anyhow to
give itself up cuz my knight has to be a
pest on that five you know why you could
deal with the knight on f5 in a queen on
g3 Canyon ha just like I suspected okay
queen here Knight here and I have some
issues let's just throw them in there I
could still play here I've doubled pawns
but they're proving useful because of
the play I now have for my rooks and
additionally they only controls this d4
square the knight isn't around to jump
in there but alright alright let's just
drop not all the way back right here is
just enough I still want to be able to
maybe triple up what about this g4 g
fork one g5 is a pain let's go here
that's preventing f5 can't do f5 yeah I
have too much control over it so there
was no rush in other words with g4 now
there might be hang on this Knight is
boxed out I'm having a flashback of a
Kramnik machine on game Kramnik Vishy
Anand where the knight is boxed out and
now jumping into this f6 square is that
going to be annoying what about this
first
is there a rush 95 and h4 my Candida
Mills I don't want this night to get
here my queen is supporting h4 let me go
at h4 I want to control this square
maybe I could get this in I'm assuming
c6 is needed otherwise you have to
contend with my knight
and my night can't be allowed to get to
have six the guy's a follow up I triple
up on F and then I the last piece I need
to get working of course would then be
my night also have a time disadvantage
big surprise
c6 I'm pretty sure you have to play c6
unless f6 is being thought about
f6 or c 6f 6 with King King here as a an
idea okay
pile up as pawns hit a third time could
I get this night away somehow pawn push
pawn push I think I'm just allowing
night here and I want to improve my King
position somehow good play rook here but
then there's this knight move that's
interfering what about first this move
actually clean here Queen g3 there still
is no advance here that's going to still
take some more work I'm doing this I
could play g5 and then rook here if I
did this move too soon I think
h6 could have been played uh how can I
get my knight working I don't have a
good place for my knight now no yeah you
know what I'm kind of kicking myself
that I didn't I need a plan and I'm not
able to come up with one so quick now
like d1 I just don't know I just don't
know what I want to do I should have
played g5
why didn't I play g5 there let's see
I just don't know what I want to do can
it be that I just don't know what I want
to do this night has to get working I
don't even know what he's going to do
though there's no I don't have a clear
plan that's my problem
that's my big problem right here at
least one of them that's one of my
problems don't just limit yourself to
that night there okay kingi to maybe
night G 1 2 H 3 I don't know I'm just
gonna move even if it's wrong that's the
actually no I'm starting to steep see
stuff see what just happens as soon as
you bring your night home things start
to uh I don't know what I want to say
here ok ok this nights gonna be pinned
though you still can't do this advance
king has to get out of that file I
should probably get out for the file
having the Queen and the king on same
file there not a good idea let's get out
of that let's just make a move cuz I'm
down on time I don't see any good
progress here yeah whoo hang on
hang on I want to get to this square now
hang on this is a juicy square Oh the
tables are turning now incoming night
f59 f5 get out of the way Queen my
knight wants to be there promise you
King up here there's Knight takes pawn
if the Queen puts pressure here I have
to defend it like this and then jump in
here so is it gonna be breaking the
center there's gonna be a pawn dropping
who dodges a bullet I was exaggerating
with that one so let's take here maybe
maybe I uh go somewhere else I'm gonna
go to this square instead this one was
appealing but I think this one might be
good too pressure on this pawn is well
night here
tricky Knights pressure on f6 directly
if I just play here the knight would
take them out but and my knight is much
more aggressive now that there's been
this capturing away from the center 46
to 126 Knight d5 being chased away to
square I was already going to go - no I
got a move quicker the Knights gonna
play here I gotta take that out that's
gonna be a problem isn't it I'm hitting
that pond three times I'm in trouble
I get my Queen active she's active she's
hitting a pawn now Queen a4 I have to
babysit this pawn is the queen gonna go
here that's a mistake now my king is
freed up me my king can run over here
okay transition time to transition King
is sneaking over I don't want to allow
well I'm gonna have to allow that oh
that wasn't a good idea I don't think
okay I'm gonna end up netting this pond
I don't know why did that movie
I'll look up here that's that's the
correct way to defend the rook has to go
back I can chase the rook off but now
it's gonna get oh I can't get sneaked in
oh I could have taken that I could have
taken that pun that's what I thought I
was able to do a bit earlier but I think
the rook is the repitch a stowaway now
might be what am I missing
oh I got the rook I got a rook here ah
this is working out now I chased the
King back first and then take this pond
how's the clock I only have 10 seconds
ah they have ten seconds eight seconds
I got a premium of stuff get the rooks
off okay I got the rooks off finally
this game transitioned big time didn't
it I don't have to grab those pawns one
of these two is gonna promote now the
King is at least cut out of five seconds
five point seven watch out for stalemate
I didn't watch out for stalemate with
that move oh man good game right down to
the wire
let's back up here reverse flip the
board oh um I don't know what to say
about this let me see my first thought
is well okay so really Lopez okay so I
just wanted to get their aggressive
Bishop off there I don't know if even
taking is is best maybe just dropping
back I don't know Bishop to Bishop to b6
take and if I do take then you have play
that's this is certainly an alternative
Bishop to b6 one thing to know and if
you are capturing don't view this as a
liability I have playing the F file so I
gave up my bishop knowing that the
bishop was probably going to still have
to give itself back up because a knight
on f5 and f4 with King side Castle
positions very difficult your
you're asking for a beating if those
Knights stick around on those squares a
Black Knight getting to f4 a white
knight getting to f5
that's an unusually number-one priority
to get rid of them
so I had some pressure here but right
here I throw away any advantage I think
I my opponent is wise to play c6 have to
keep my knight out of f6 maybe there
were some cases where I could have
played my rook but what again turned me
off - that was some night move to f4
interfering and then there would be
maybe a fourth on h3 let's see if we can
quickly get to that position after
Queenie 7 Queen gf6 I believe I have
nothing here I think just keeping these
pawns sitting and my knight is still
without a home and this is a pretty
strong placement for your knight
so if there's maybe one critical
position towards this end game stage
it's right here and if I am to play g5
why was I so afraid of h6 to undermine
my structure I could just take it yeah
that that that's actually that's my that
was my concern g5 I thought h6 and I
couldn't maintain my pawn on g5 as far
as I could tell I don't think I can
maintain it so I believe I have to give
it up
pawn takes King here actually I couldn't
be able to play King here ever and my
opponent would be able to play here
because the pressure I still have on F
so I think this is would have been an
improvement playing g5 and clamping down
on f6 and then dropping that rook into
f6 would have been much different but
because of that inning what is it
because I was inaccurate with Queen g3
f6 was a good move and I think just
keeping these pawns sitting I don't have
anything where I did have something was
only after upon advance as soon as I saw
h6 I thought I had I had something
because I knew then I could always play
h5 to make this pawn flinch and then
this would become a weak square but just
keeping this as is I don't know that I
really do much I think it would be a
drawn position in fact at this point
right here I was close to just offering
a drop seeing how I was the side who was
down on time and I didn't see a clear
plan I don't know how to pursue this
position further any pond if I do upon
advance we're just going to have a bunch
of rook exchanges your knight again is
very very well placed in the current
state of the knight positions right here
that they're really just canceling one
another out two nights on the same
diagonal with exactly two squares are
often just fighting for those same
squares in this case g5 f4 so if you
just sit right here I really don't have
anything
there's no weaknesses in the black
position so this is really just a draw
but I started to have some hope and
while there was an opportunity to grab
this pawn but we were pretty much blitz
mode at that point when it comes to the
rook and pawn endgame I don't really
know who's better I know that there was
a missed opportunity for me right here
as soon as rook played back I should be
taking this pawn but I missed that my
opponent was wisely on top of it one
move later I have a little bit better of
a king position and well I guess I am
able to net this pawn at the end of it
all I ended up dropping but we were
blitzing stuff very quickly at that
point all right um very very good game
down to the wire again